so what i have here are 12 pieces of
candy and the ones that are colored in
brown are made out of i have chocolate
on the outside and the ones that have a
c on them means that they have coconut
on the inside so for example this one
over here in the top left it's made out
of chocolate on the outside but it
doesn't have coconut on the inside while
this one right over here does is
chocolate on the outside and has coconut
on the inside while this one whoops i
didn't want to do that
while this one while this one right over
here it does not have chocolate on the
outside but it does have coconut on the
inside and this one right over here has
neither chocolate nor coconut and what i
want to think about is ways to represent
this information that we are looking at
and one way to do it is using a venn
diagram so let me draw a venn diagram
so
then
diagram is one way to represent it
and the way it's typically done the
convention is that you would make a
rectangle to represent the universe that
you care about in this case it would be
all the chocolate so all the numbers
inside of this should add up to the
number of chocolates i have so it should
add up to 12.
so that's our universe right over here
and then i'll draw circles to represent
the sets that i care about so say for
this one i care about the set of the
things that have chocolate
so i'll draw that with a circle it's not
oftentimes you could draw them to scale
but i'm not going to draw them to scale
so that is my chocolate set
chocolate
that is my chocolate set
and then i'll have a coconut set
so
coconut
once again not drawn to scale i'd roam
roughly the same size but there's
actually you can see the chocolate set
is bigger than the coconut set in
reality coconut
set and now we can fill in the different
sections
so how many of these things have
chocolate but no coconut
let's see we have one
two
three
four
five
six have chocolate but no coconut
so that's going to be actually let me do
that in a different color because i
think the colors are important so let me
do it in green
so one two three four
five and six
so this section right over here is six
and once again i'm not talking about the
whole brown thing i'm talking about just
this area that i've shaded in green
now how many have chocolate and coconut
chocolate and coconut
well that's going to be
one
two
three so three of them have chocolate
and coconut and notice that's this
section here that's in the overlap
between three of them go into both sets
both categories these three have coconut
and they have chocolate how many total
have chocolate well six plus three nine
how many have total have coconut well
we're gonna have to figure that out in a
second
so how many have coconut but no
chocolate
well there's only
one with coconut and no chocolate so
that's that one right over there and
that represents this area that i'm
shading in in white so how many total
coconut are there well one plus three or
four and you see that one two three four
and then the last thing we'd want to
fill in because notice six plus three
plus one only adds up to ten what about
the other two well the other two are
neither chocolate nor coconut actually
let me color this so that's one two
these are neither chocolate nor coconut
and i could write these two right over
here these are neither chocolate nor
coconut so that's one way to represent
to represent the information of what
what how many chocolates how many
coconuts and how many chocolate and
coconuts and how many neither but
there's other ways that we could do it
another way to do it would be with a
two-way table
to
a
two-way table
and on one axis say the vertical axis we
could say
let me write this
so has chocolate
has chocolate
i'll write chalk for short and then i'll
write no chocolate
no
chocolate chalk for short and then over
here i could write coconut no i want to
do that in white
i got new tools and sometimes the color
changing isn't so easy so this is
coconut
coconut and then over here all right no
no
coconut
no coconut and then let me make a little
table
let me make a table make it clear what
i'm doing here
so a line there
and a line there and then why not a line
over here as well
and then i can just fill in the
different things so how many have this
cell right or this square this is going
to represent the number that has coconut
and chocolate coconut and chocolate well
we already looked into that that's one
two three that's these three right over
here so that's those three right over
there
this one right over here me is it has
chocolate but it doesn't have coconut
well that's this six right over here has
so let me write
this is that six right over there and
then it has this this box would be it
has coconut but no chocolate well how
many is that well coconut no chocolate
that's that one there and this one is
going to be no coconut and no chocolate
and we know what that's going to be
no coconut and no no chocolate is going
to be 2. and if we wanted to we could
even throw in total totals over here we
could write actually let me just do that
just for fun i could write total
i could write total
and if i total it vertically
if i total it vertically so three plus
one this is four six plus two is eight
so this four is the total number that
have coconut the both the has chocolate
and doesn't have chocolate and that's
the three plus one
this eight is a total that does not have
the total that does not have coconut
right no coconuts the total of no
coconut and that of course is going to
be the six plus this two and we could
total horizontally three plus six is 9 1
plus 2 is 3. what's this 9 that's a
total amount of chocolate 6 plus 3.
what's this 3 this is a total amount no
chocolate that's this 1 plus 2. anyway
hopefully you found that interesting
this is just just different ways of
representing the same information